over the past few weeks I've heard from
some of the smartest medical minds in
America about both the nature of this
hideous virus and the most promising
treatments that are currently under
investigation because other countries
have been dealing with this longer and
on a larger scale some of them are ahead
of us on finding the best drug
treatments on Monday I told you about
two of them the anti-malarial drug
chloroquine and its sister had rocks the
chloroquine manufactured by Sanofi labs
now today the issue was brought up at
the White House briefing by our own John
Roberts dr. Burton researchers have had
some luck with hydroxychloroquine in
shortening the duration of disease is
that something that might be in the
arsenal of therapeutics here in the
United States I think we are exploring
every one of those issues there is
things that look really good in cell
culture against the virus that may look
good in small animals and then don't
have an impact in humans of course
there's always antidotal reports and
we're trying to figure out how many Ana
Dodos reports equal real scientific
breakthroughs well I'm not sure what she
meant by anecdotal but the renowned
French researcher an infectious disease
specialist professor Didier Rowe was
tasked by the French government to
examine possible cures for Cova 19:00
and yesterday he described his results
as promising good news in a video posted
on the internet he said that the first
batch of 24 Cova 19 patients that he had
treated with the drug chloroquine had
seen a rapid ineffective speeding up of
their healing process and a sharp
decrease in the amount of time they
remain contagious yes
well China in South Korea the country's
hardest hit with kovin 19 they've
already developed guidelines for
physicians who are prescribing the use
of chloroquine in hydroxychloroquine its
treatment options it's not just in
animals and it's not just in a lab
chloroquine was chosen after China did
several screening rounds of thousands of
existing drugs chloroquine is undergoing
further trials and more than 10
hospitals there now whatever the press
it has to do to cut red tape and bring
clear treatment options such as this and
also preventatives to Americans he needs
to do it and I bet it's coming soon
which brings me to my next point
demanding total cooperation and openness
from China or else in a pandemic it's
essential that our health experts work
cooperatively with other countries and
that we all share data and findings
about the disease as we try to stop its
spread all over the world wonderful and
brave doctors I've been able to talk to
some of them who are treating Koba 19
patients are posting their findings
online and you can read some of them and
even chat rooms where the doctors are
talking to each other it's fantastic but
we need the Chinese government to give
us total and complete access to all
their scientific data including by the
way the findings of doctors who first
studied and discovered the virus some of
that information was apparently
destroyed well we want to find it we
want it back we want to know everything
about patient zero we want to know
everything about the true recovery rates
the true mortality rates including those
who were locked in their apartments and
left to die in Wuhan and if China isn't
willing to work with us think about this
in defeating this pandemic and ensuring
that something like this never happens
again look what happened to the American
people today their their their stock
holdings their 401ks many people losing
their jobs think about this if they're
not operating in total transparency
regarding this disease then we have to
ask ourselves why we want to continue to
be integrated with them at all on any
issue we have nothing against the
Chinese people just like we didn't have
anything against the Russian people
during the Cold War but President Xi and
his Politburo have have to come clean
here or we need to reconsider or
consider frankly taking severe measures
against Beijing we need a new industrial
policy made in the USA all the way if
they don't come clean we have to revoke
China's most favored nation
status for trade we have to ban Chinese
investment in the US we have to strictly
limit Chinese travel to the United
States and by the way forget that second
phase of the trade deal we have to add
tariffs well that should get their
attention don't you think not only has
China thus far refused to allow our top
medical officials access to all the data
all the hospitals all the premier
researchers they're kicking out our
journalists who are actually there
trying to report the truth about what
happened going back to November December
January and what didn't happen
the New York Times reporting that the
Chinese government cast its expulsion of
the journalists as necessary to defend
Beijing against what it perceived as an
ideological campaign by the United
States to impose its values on China
yeah the value of truth and yet despite
all this despite what's happened despite
how awful this has gotten for people all
around the world and of course here
somehow somehow there are American
journalists who are still fretting about
China's feelings why do you keep calling
this the Chinese virus it's not racist
at all no matter no it comes from China
that's why comes from China borders
a person at the White House you used it
to crystalline flu my question is come
flu nothing no no I don't think I know
who where it came from
it comes from China and it's not a
question about that good for Trump oh
and when we're not worried about the
virus is nomenclature we apparently want
to help the economy of the country
responsible for our national nightmare
look China's paying us billions and
billions of dollars in tariffs and
there's no reason to do that we're
getting billions of dollars here from
tariffs from China and
I can't imagine Americans asking for
that yeah well the question was telling
you to take your tariffs off China now
shouldn't you do this given the
unbelievable
now look at how much time was lost
because China covered it up at the end
of last year covered up the virus they
threaten doctors they refused to allow
independent medical teams in to assess
the situation in its handling of kovat
19 and this is gonna sound tough but
China has blood on its hands one recent
study found that if China had
implemented its control measures a week
earlier it could have prevented 67
percent of all cases they're
implementing the measures three weeks
earlier from the beginning of January
would have cut the number of infections
to five percent of the total and yet the
w-h-o wants everyone to think that what
it's it's which was to fawn over China's
containment efforts that's ridiculous we
cannot sit by and let our people have
their lives threatened our entire
economy devastated not by a contagion
that originated in China a country that
still refuses to allow the NIH
unfettered access I was thinking about
this today how first of all how blessed
I am to be able to have a job and keep
working during all of this and to have
all of you watching every night have my
health and my family's health but I
thought about the millions and millions
of Americans who work their butts off
every day and see their dream their
dream of having a retirement someday
putting their kids through college
vanish because of this virus much if not
all of this could have been avoided if
China had only been forthcoming from day
one my friends this cannot stand and
that's the angle